hey guys now I got this question from
some of you you asked Daniel what colors
of clothes do I need to wear that will
fit in with my skintone
now I need to make this very clear first
of all please remember not to make style
too complicated because style is a form
of expression so if you want to wear a
certain color just do it now with that
said of course it's a few guidelines
that can improve your look but it is not
as complicated as many people make so
let's jump right into the video and I'll
explain it to you all right now
there's basically three different colors
right you got your fair skin tone you
got your medium skin tone and then dark
right and all three of them will fit in
really well with neutral colors neutral
colors is and always will be the
backbone of a great wardrobe why well
because all the neutral colors like
black white gray maybe all of khaki or
camel and brown work together
harmoniously all of them look good on
everyone and it's not too overpowering
like those bright colors now let me just
explain this because there's nothing
wrong with bright colors it actually
looks really good on menuhim dark skin
tones but it looks terrible when guys
overdo it and it comes off as showy yes
of course style is a form of expression
and you are free to express yourself but
here's the thing most people won't
really like it when you try too hard and
when you look like a kind of rainbow now
the cool thing about neutral colors is
that you actually don't need to know
anything about color match because they
all work together now with that being
said if your skin tone is
fair or pale then try to wear the
opposite of your own skin tone meaning
stay away from white or light beige or
even stone might not work as well rather
we're richer colors like camel sand or
slate grey for at least just mix the
dark colors with light ones and that's
actually the same for guys of other skin
tones try to wear the opposite of your
own skin tone because if you just wear
the same colors as your own skin tone
then you won't really stand out that
much now just some last advice the
colors you pick should be more about the
vibe or the feeling that you want to
give up and not so much about wearing
the perfect color for your skin tone now
if you want some more tips to improve
yourself and check out one of these
videos and I'll see you there cheers
guys